right now hayward is on the terracumbo
goes across the lane pass outside wesley
matthews
bang i've been waiting to say that for
months
is a different bucks team in several
subtle ways going into the playoffs and
west matthews the third even though
he's been their defensive stopper look
at gamma giannis i'm seeing the number
one defensive team in the league of
milwaukee bucks but here's giannis going
left side
and uh does a nice job it's really tough
when he's got a head of steam coming in
i think teams should pick him up higher
in transition
middleton with a hand in his face knocks
down the three and the foul by tatum
in the category of being one of those
great defensive teams
i think they're a very good defensive
team i wouldn't put them on my goodness
he has eight points seven rebounds
couple of assists
like exhibition games for boston
and milwaukee as far as the impact it
has on
seating as giannis makes a three
brown a plus 40 percent three-point
shooter that's not exactly the shot you
[Applause]
the most underrated second best player
on a team in basketball
doesn't get enough credit and just like
that
pretty easy to the rim
antenna as harden tries to get the
charge
count the basket and the foul he just
kept playing
but the ability to still stick with the
play and
pursuit of basketball it looks like a
turnover then all of a sudden he wants
it more
takes the contact in that first round
to me if i'm the rockets right now the
way the clippers are designed
the ability to defend the perimeter that
be my worst matchup
westbrook dribbles into traffic and lost
it
they do a great job of protecting the
paint sterling brown
a follow two on him
westbrook pass deflected and tedekumpo
first
got a piece of it nice feed from
middleton kicks it out ilya silva who
just checked in his layup
is good at both ends of the floor
middleton on the pull-up boy that's just
a good-looking shot
and then throws up an air ball he's
going to have to shoot it he's going to
have a lot of chances
and a blocking foul call as the third
combo goes and knocks down jeff green
you gotta you he has to see a wall he
can't just look up and see jeff green
because he puts his head down gets an
angle
that's a foul
getting great looks though coach yeah
and brook lopez is going to continue to
come
and count the paint and one middleton
gets mclemore up in the air
so solid can shoot the basketball so he
gets you in the air with that little
shot fake and then
takes the contact shooting one
he's pretty good mike putin
luau camaro giannis lays it in
easy for you to say opening game of the
the seating games he had 24.
i said akumbo another three
and giannis has hit his first two from
deep
if you're eric schwarzer that's a
welcome sight to see the rookie kindred
young knocked down his first shot
remember as stephanie just reported no
gorn dragons the third leading scorers
middleton answers with the three himself
collected by middleton here comes
giannis the other way
accelerates and tries oh my goodness
he was out of the block and blew by him
with an explosive move
on tnt
adebayo looking inside lopez just
knocked it away
swaps it out of the air picked up by
giannis the strides the drive
and the athleticism creating
offense from your defense
but houston is the extreme right i mean
yes miami's got all the things that they
want oh there's a great chunk off that
baseline bionics
how about the quick move here by giannis
goes baseline wonderable
what a beautiful 12 for this first half
for miami and they've taken 22 so
they're right on pace what they've done
the previous couple games three
middleton bucket
it's chris middleton putting it in
giannis is in williams is out
evangenzo and hill and the defensive
length as well
oh great spin move pie out of the combo
beautiful pirouette
tries to maneuver by it and his
mid-range shot is no good
lopez got a hand on it volleyball's it
out middleton thinking three
taking three and buries the three just
walks right into a three-point ball
partly cloudy partly cloudy
ej thank you middleton
from these two elite players shot clock
running down just
he called he's one of the most improved
players i've ever seen in the nba
from a weak defender until now he's now
a dominant defender
on the drive middleton gets the layup
from every area of the floor here drives
it left
mavericks with the hot hand they've made
seven in a row for the floor
curry driving rejected by the greek
freak out of play
and zero dante great chance of being
named defensive player of the year
dallas has been a historically great
offense
with the shooting that they surround
doncic with
and with multiple playmakers
middleton gets the bounce he's got six
points now jumbo has two points both
coming
at the line over two from the field it's
guarded by cleva
spins on him gets to the rim and lays it
up and in
plus a foul put your whole body
he's doing the same thing time and time
again i'm not
even so sure you shouldn't once he
starts left
you shouldn't keep him going left
here's middleton relatively quiet first
half
nine points three of six shooting he's
fouled there it goes
and he'll go to the line what a second
quarter by milwaukee
nine-point lead at the three-minute mark
of ot
about 26 points for finney smith there's
giannis with the slam and that ends
the drought time thought about it missed
it here come the bucks again
middleton good on the three ten points
early in that
first quarter finished with 12 in the
first half
middleton two-time all-star was held to
six nice look to lopez who lays it in
wait no and still not get into the
western conference playing
and then you have san antonio in the mix
as well
[Applause]
the magic more than capable on any given
night of beating
anybody in the nba let's see if they are
up to the challenge
chris middleton is gets the first bucket
of the game and greg he's a match-up
nightmare
44 from the three-point line in the
bubble
good job on the close-out
i'll tell you what how about that to
start the playoffs giannis with a three
and they were a clean team for the most
part during the regular season at that
cumball in the spin and the hammer
oh my goodness yes and you see
that rotation weak side not coming at
all looks like they're playing a zone
look at the three round good positioning
george hill
he found the soft spot underneath they
were 24th in the league in scoring
before the restart and you saw the
the significant improvement chris
middleton
tried to defend a two guard that long
made
lopez commit just enough to give boots
that space
adeta kumbo banks in a three
the magic's partnership with the frc
has been conducting a voter registration
campaign with the theme
[Applause]
it's been middleton who is struggling to
contain
that movement and he's going to get an
m1 there against ross
they needed it you see it just
initiates the contact and then able to
here's the tenecumple
getting downhill against fournier wow
that is unstoppable missed their last 13
in a row doris
connaughton from the wing and pat
conaton
knocks down the long ball so obviously
the plan is to wall up giannis onto
cumpo and look at look at the three guys
standing at the free-throw line
and so that's going to create a lot of
shot opportunities ross does try to
challenge
with the rebound and they got some time
two seconds to go
giannis it'll count they got the bucket
with point four to go
in the first half vogel commented to me
that the lakers need anthony davis to
make threes it helps their spacing
but you know kentavious oh my gosh
say it with your chest giannis 24 points
18
boards and he is a terror coming at you
[Applause]
good night
that is a wonderful poster hey
a miss from distance markelle fultz here
comes giannis
downhill we haven't seen perhaps as much
downhill movement
by giannis nicely played by marvin
williams
so four-point lead for the bucks
middleton got it
and already a much better looking stroke
from middleton
challenge without fouling and the magic
making a nice run
off their defense and
[Applause]
about the importance of the bench david
and
these guys every time he missed i was
shocked
and i had a sigh of relief yet he's
turning back
birch just so difficult against this
team and right now
they're just unable to keep milwaukee
away from the rim
plus milwaukee's defense is stepping up
back to middleton for the easiest shot
he's had in his series a wide open three
middleton again and he's fouled
right here middleton goes to the basket
and again another foul
on a jump shooter and this is what
happens when a shooter gets going
people want to contest more and the
rebound by
yanis there comes the mvp to the biscuit
nasty finish
fultz and he created the contact they
said
as bledsoe the love for giannis
he had matthews as a decoy on one side
giannis floating down the lane
blob up and when you got a guy like
giannis you just got to get it up
anywhere near
the basket feeling pretty good you've
only scored 18 you've struggled but your
defense has kept you in this game
giannis got it before they say it hit
the window and
another turnover sudden things get a
little easier and a half court
he's filling up the box with five and
five four assists as well for nick
the challenge three middleton and that's
big for chris middleton
now chris middleton just one bucket like
borne but a great entry
as iana slipped the screen middleton
found him
making ability he just holds it for that
one count
and then able to deliver that that's at
6 30 on tnt
and the blazers and the lakers later
tonight
well they keep matching it
a little euro action and then some some
talk on the way and that's the
uniqueness
of giannis you can see that play there
that is just
there's not a lot you can do when you
get to the launching pad
rebound saved by birds through the five
hole right to divacenzo
so a break from milwaukee and look out
at a combo
and that's that live ball turnover there
so dennicumbo up to 25 and 10 with seven
assists triple double territory already
came in averaging 31-16 and there's
chris middleton
that is huge for down the road clark
already has three threes
and it's starting to get away isn't it
yeah
13-point game and middleton goes to the
line looking to complete a four-point
play
full threes and that's all a great
shooter needs just to see
and it's poked away and stolen by
middleton
so many turnovers early middleton nice
crossover christine gets delayed
middleton he's got eight points
bledsoe finds middleton middleton inside
for an easy and the foul
well they were running him off his shot
good pass by bledsoe
good attack of the closeout and then a
beautiful extra pass
by middleton to giannis ross picks up
his first
as you see he got hit in the head let's
see matthews checks back in
sometimes you forget as time goes on who
actually
drafted somebody as middleton backs in
for the bucket
it's the same way with steph curry in
golden state
bledsoe lot alley
and the lead is 14 largest of the first
half
he cuts and then the pick and roll and a
beautiful find by
they're gonna try to get a two for one
here
middleton three-pointer count it and the
foul
middleton with a chance for a four-point
play
what you need they're going to need
chris middleton
to come up big and big moments this
obviously is not one of them
but his production every day production
as in it's clearly 1000.
it's going to be critical yeah ali's
such an emotional week for the bucks and
just everything about this
nba restart has felt different butler
turned back
that is that all league defense as
middleton
fills up a three but look at this
defense by the league mvp
as eric bledsoe inactive late scratch
right hamstring injury
if you've just hopped on with us for the
bucks here's middleton a deep three
get it make it 10 for the all-star
as much as there are three-point
shooters we watch middleton knock it in
jimmy butler and then with the the young
players that he'd have
getting a lot of very deserved notoriety
people have forgotten about draggage but
he has been outstanding
the defense has almost no chance lopez
and middleton 19 apiece crowders pass
intercepted by middleton
off the theft to the rim made the back
door cut on the last possession now
twice has used that window
from a nice angle
middleton shot around and down count it
and one
super aggressive in the first half
there's the bump by robinson
and a little friendly roll it is a home
game after all
two and a half to go in the first gianna
setting the screen for hill
hill keeps it now dumps it down low
adena kubo rises
and smashes it and what would that mean
for the rockets if they were to lose
that game
here's butler rejected by the great
frank
there's got to be one more extra pass to
duncan robinson on your left long three
middleton good boy is he shooting well
to start things
three or three simple in transition
little hesitation fake and just raises
up
middleton has been great four
consecutive 20 plus point games for the
bucks
but you hold them back all season long
for moments like this so that's why
during the regular season he's playing
34 to 36 minutes come playoff time
that's supposed to increase
turnover miami lopez a triple by 10.
miami came back and really now they're
trying to
stop the spinning onto the kumble and
that's going to be a tough chore
well maybe he's finding life
he's the sp jump stopped pivoted away
and made the mid-ranger that stop and
pivot is so important to have
and that move by combo so important a
half for the milwaukee bucks
and here come the bucks
[Applause]
three-pointer that's good he had missed
11 consecutive threes in this series
that started with a bledsoe long rebound
again
draggage has it taken away bledsoe
responsible there kyle korver his first
shot that's good
i'm playing the five no matter what and
brook said okay i guess i'll play the
four and learn how to
play multiple positions what a fine came
over in that trade in february with
iguodala
nice little head second all-star on this
basketball team he's got to take it upon
himself to
be a playmaker
i mean they are just a handful at that
end
[Applause]
baskets all the way over to matthew's
cross-court pass and matthews with his
first points
of the game the two-time all-star chris
middleton
lasers one inside nice catch and two the
result and matthews gets it
when you're playing for the guy standing
beside you you can go
that much harder you can dig that much
deeper and kevin and reggie
their rally friday night you gotta love
this play loose and relaxed right
shot clock at nine here's middleton
again and crowder sticks with them
three good nice shot outside
playing the miami style holding the ball
shooting it well and coming out with an
early lead in the first on
tnt three-point game
bucks trying to avoid elimination
picked off by middleton into crowder
to the rack and slammed in by davincenzo
there's that defense i was just alluding
to approaching two to play in the third
middleton
shifting gears and a crowder and a foul
count it
and in transition middleton who has
struggled shooting the basketball to
contact by crowder